foreign
two versions of the same blade
One winner
forged in fire weapons Showdown now
we're sending you back to your home for
just to recreate an iconic weapon from
history and from Hollywood that weapon
is
Hattori Hanzo a thousand layer Katana
whoa
each blade must pass three tests the
kill test the sharpness test the
strength test
good luck blade Smiths we'll see you in
five days let's do this man all right
my name is Mike divert I am a journeyman
bladesman here in Trussville Alabama
getting ready to start the Hattori Hanzo
Katana here we go I've never made a
thousand layers it's gonna be incredibly
difficult I really need to do this right
the first time and that's my initial
well if I mess this up I'm done
I like to have at least half of my
Billet forged up today maybe 500 maybe
more layers this is where the fun stuff
begins
grinding with a grinder
so now I have my my Billet divided into
five pieces and I will restack these and
weld them together
I am truly blessed to have a press and a
power hammer by hand this is very
difficult and slow so now I'm at 620
layers all I have to do is cut it in
half weld those two halves together and
now I have 1240 layers I actually feel
good because I have more than the
required number of layers so now I can
go into my heat treat I don't typically
do blades this long
so what I need to do is put two forges
together to create an even heat
throughout this blade as I get ready to
harden it
[Music]
I pull the blade out see I'm starting to
get a warp in it
part of me wants to freak out by the
time the blade is cooled down a lot I
see that it's got essentially two bends
in it
I quenched the second time the blade has
a slight warp in it but it's something I
can be ground out so I'm really happy
right now now I just need to start
making all the handle Parts I have the
habaki
fitting up nicely the Suba is right here
this handle has to be tight the sword is
going to be beat up
so now it's going to be wrapped in
stingray skin and Ito cord
I'm pretty happy with it my name is
Tristan Nguyen I'm 19. and I'm making a
hitori Hanzo style Katana I've never
done something this big before I'm going
to start by working on my 1000 layer
Damascus so the weld looks like it held
together really well good start good
start the problem with the Thousand
layer Damascus is that there is 999
spots in the Billet that's possibly
going to go wrong if I had power tools I
feel like I could have pumped this out a
lot faster it's taking forever I thought
that I was going to be able to get a
thousand layers done in one day I've got
42 layers but being at 42 layers is
still only three Forge worlds away from
being in over a thousand
yesterday I was able to forge my
thousand layer Billet but it's looking
it's looking lean so in order to get the
weight that I need I Forge welded mild
steel to the back and the sides of it I
think it will make the blade stronger
I'm doing the heat treat on my Katana
with charcoal and I'm pretty nervous
this is the make or break moment
the quench is insanely critical for the
completion of this piece this blade
needs to be perfect if anything goes
wrong I won't be able to finish this
piece if there's a warp that goes the
wrong way I don't know if there's any
straightening out with this type of
Steel
straight
the first thing I want to get done is
carve out the Suka I'm using a piece of
Walnut it's just a really strong wood
it's starting to look really nice after
I finish carving it out I'm going to put
some Ray skin on the sides of it and
give it a wrap my biggest deviation from
the tradition is I'm using shoelaces for
my wrap it just feels the nicest but
they're shoelaces
yeah Everything feels really together
let's go hit things
[Music]
yes
Mike your Edge is razor sharp but more
importantly there's bone on your Edge
but your Edge didn't roll did not chip
and your blade stayed true
overall sir your blade
will kill
thank you
Justin you ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
right Tristan the balance of your blade
is very good it's light it's fast it's
easily maneuverable
but
when steel meets the skull there was
some problems
your Blade the serious Bend also on the
edge right here you took some chipping
but overall looking at the dummy I think
your weapon will definitely kill
thank you
[Music]
you're blade sir is sharp it cut cleany
to the thickest of our tatami mats but
on the backhand slice it did not cut
completely though overall sir your sword
will cut
thank you Justin your turn you ready
ready as I'll ever be sir let's do this
what's up
[Music]
well Tristan your Edge is sharp
it can cut through the tummy mats my
concern is the strength of your blade
it picked up another Bend
now you have two bends on your blade
especially right here close to the guard
Tristan this Hollywood competition has
been exciting and dramatic you've been
at the epicenter of all of that drama
nobody is questioning the strength of
your character however the strength of
your blade is such that we can no longer
continue to test it
that reason I have to ask you to please
leave a forge sir
I guess I just couldn't flip there
objectively speaking one of the blades
is better than the other and it's clear
to see because one of them is straight I
may not be Fortune fire Champion but
second place isn't bad for somebody
who's never done this before
Mike you're an Unstoppable force in this
competition and your hatari Hanzo
thousand layer Katana is absolutely
deadly earning you the title of forged
and fire champion and a check for 10
grand good job brother I came here to
show myself that I can make a blade
worthy of undergoing this type of
punishment I am forged and fire champion
and it feels awesome forged in fire
weapon Showdown